.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON
TONIGHT.
BEST OF LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BLAKE MASTERS IS RUNNING IN
THE OTHER BIG RACE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS NOWHERE
NEAR BEING SETTLED.
MASTERS SAYS HE CAN STILL WIN
HIS RACE OR IT HE SAYS THERE IS
EVIDENCE OF TRUE SCREW UPS IN
BALLOT COUNTING.
COUNTED BALLOTS, UNCOUNTED
BALLOTS SOMEHOW GETTING
COMMINGLED INTO THE SAME PILE.
WE ASKED, ARIZONA, OFFICIALS FO
RESPONSIVE CLAIMS AND HAVE HEAR
NOTHING BACK FROM THAT.
MASTERS JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
TELL US WHAT YOU BELIEVE
HAPPENED IN SOME CASES TO
BALLOTS IN MARICOPA COUNTY,
ARIZONA.
>> WE ARE IN A DOGFIGHT IN
MY RACE WILL BE VERY CLOSE.
IT'S GOING TO BE DECIDED BY A
FEW THOUSAND VOTES EITHER WAY
BUT THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS OUTSTANDIN
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN COUNTED YET
WHICH APPARENTLY IS HARD FOR
MARICOPA COUNTY.
THE PROBLEM STARTED TUESDAY
MORNING WHEN 20-30 PERCENT OF
THE VOTING TABULATION MACHINES
DIDN'T WORK.
THIS WASN'T A SURPRISE WHEN
ELECTION DAY WAS BRIGHT IT JUST
DIDN'T WORK.
WHAT IS THAT?
INCOMPETENCE AT THE VERY WORST.
THEN IT GOT WORSE, SO PEOPLE
WHEN THEY GOT TO MACHINE AND TH
MACHINE DIDN'T WORK, THEY WERE
INVITED TO DROP THEIR BALLOT IN
A SECURE BOX.
IT TURNS OUT MARICOPA COUNTY ON
AT LEAST TWO OCCASIONS MIXED UP
THOSE UNCOUNTED BALLOTS WITH
BALLOTS THAT IT ALREADY BEEN
COUNTED.
SO IT'S A GIANT MESS TO TRY TO
UNMIXED THESE BALLOTS.
I THINK THE MOST HONEST THING A
THIS POINT WOULD BE FOR MARICOP
COUNTY TO WIPE THE SLATE CLEAN,
TAKE ALL THE BALLOTS AND DO A
FRESH COUNT.
>> Tucker: HOW COULD THEY NOT
DO THAT?
WHETHER YOU WIN OR LOSE THEM A
BIT IF YOU CARE ABOUT DEMOCRACY
YOU WOULD DEMAND THAT EVERY VOT
IS COUNTED AND NOT DOUBLE
COUNTED, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I THINK ARIZONANS DESERVE MUCH
BETTER.
MARICOPA COUNTY ELECTIONS, MAY
BE THEY ARE WORKING HARD, GOD
BLESS HIM, IT'S AT BEST,
INCOMPETENT.
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS ALSO IN
THE PEOPLE THEY CONTROLLED THE
PURSE STRINGS.
MITCH McCONNELL, McCONNELL
DECIDED TO SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ATTACKING A FELLOW
REPUBLICAN IN ALASKA INSTEAD OF
HELPING ME DEFEAT SENATOR MARK
KELLY.
MY MESSAGE TO THE PEOPLE OF
MARICOPA COUNTY, ACTUALLY TO MY
FELLOW REPUBLICAN SENATORS IN M
FUTURE COLLEAGUES, LET'S NOT
DEVOTE ITS McCONNELL INTO
LEADERSHIP.
HE DOESN'T DESERVE TO BE
MINORITY OR MAJORITY LEADER.
YOU CAN STAND WITH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR YOU CAN STAND
FOR IT MITCH McCONNELL.
UNLIKE ENOUGH TO REPRESENT
ARIZONA IN THE U.S. SENATE NEXT
YEAR, I THINK IT AS CLEAR WHAT
WILL STAND.
>> WHY WOULDN'T, HE SPENT MONEY
ON PRIMARIES IN ALASKA.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIG SENATE
RACES IN THE COUNTRY, AND HE
AVOIDED IT.
WHY WOULDN'T HE SUPPORT YOU I
WONDER?
>> I WILL LEAVE IT TO THE VIEWE
TO DECIDE WHETHER IT IS MALICE
OR WHETHER IT IS GROSS
INCOMPETENCE.
CLEARLY MITCH McCONNELL CLEARS
CARES ABOUT MITCH McCONNELL.
I THINK WE NEED THAT CHANGE AND
THAT'S WHY I.
>> Harris: OFFIC